the buzz about the batman is full of ups
and downs on the one hand it's the
darkest most frightening vision of the
dark knight yet on the other that makes
it easy to wonder why this batman's so
bulletproof these are the best and worst
things about the batman i don't care
what happens to me
it's only going to get worse for you
batman is known for his combat prowess
in most iterations of the character he's
traveled the world and learned countless
methods of hand-to-hand combat on all
forms of martial arts in the batman he
seemingly acquired most of his talent
from alfred a man who this time around
we learn little about regardless batman
doesn't disappoint as he dismantles the
criminal element piece by piece using
almost nothing but his fists the opening
sequence where we see the dark knight
approach a violent street gang is the
first introduction we have to the heroes
capabilities on the ground the cocky
leader taunts and assaults a costume man
he clearly doesn't understand and
quickly learns a lesson the hard way
batman's attack is swift and merciless
if the sounds of brutality are any
indication this thug will likely be
eating through a straw for a while at
the other end of the film when the
riddler and axis plan to flood gotham we
once again witness batman's talent for
dishing out pain as he takes on several
of riddler's followers all of whom are
armed to the teeth batman's armor
deflects bullets while he expertly moves
from person to person putting each out
of commission the fight choreography is
tight and exciting to watch throughout
the film
make no mistake the batman costume looks
great and robert pattinson wears the new
bat suit well beyond aesthetics however
there is an unexplained durability to
the suit that becomes rather conspicuous
in the movie sure batman is going to
develop an armor that can withstand some
gunfire that's a given but how about
armor that can withstand a barrage of
gunfire throughout the film batman is
shot directly countless times and is
typically no worse for wear in the third
act he takes several hits from automatic
weapons a shotgun blast to the chest and
even high caliber rounds from hostile
snipers to almost no effect in the
middle of the batman our hero finds
himself in the police precinct after
being rendered unconscious by the
riddler's explosive execution of d8 gil
coulson this means that aside from
gunfire he's also taken the full force
of a bomb explosion up close then when
he escapes the entire police force he
glides away from danger in his wingsuit
however he doesn't quite nail the
landing and instead his parachute is
caught on a bridge smashing the hero
into a moving vehicle on the concrete
while he does hobble away in pain he
recovers rather quickly to continue his
vigilante work which seems to indicate
that he didn't suffer too greatly for
all intents and purposes this armor
seems a little too magical
the riddler is a frightening foe at
least in matt reeves version of the
character batman is known for
maintaining a coterie of supervillains
who are mostly insane or mentally
unstable the joker typically might win
in the creep factor department but in
this version of the batman lore the
riddler operates like an absolute
nightmare if we didn't know any better
the opening scene alone where the
riddler stalks the mayor before
bludgeoning him to death might indicate
that we're watching a slasher horror
film aside from the riddler's murderous
methods he seems to enjoy savouring his
kills he stands in the shadows for quite
some time watching the mayor pacing only
a few feet from him while watching the
news coverage of his campaign for
re-election later the ritzler provides
the media with footage of him killing
the current police commissioner using a
jigsaw-like trap in which rats are
guided through a maze and ultimately
forced to attack the commissioner's face
to escape it's a dark and macabre
setting for a villain who's completely
unhinged and ready to do anything to
achieve his goals the horror elements of
this film are jarring and unforgettable
paul dano's performance of the character
continues to deliver terror even after
he's unmasked and sitting behind
hardened glass opposite batman his
erratic yelling and pervasive tics all
tell a story we know that the riddler
had a horrible childhood and it clearly
made him a horrible man
one of the film's most intense moments
is when batman gives chase to the
penguin believing him to be the rat the
riddler is leading him to the monstrous
batmobile roars onto the scene letting
the penguin know there's no escape
despite the reality of an angry batman
burning rubber and a jacked hot rod with
a steel frame the penguin still attempts
to shake his pursuer the only way he
knows how by driving head first and
oncoming traffic eventually the penguin
causes a massive pileup leading to an
explosion it briefly seems as though the
penguin has either lost the batman or
killed him as he speeds away however the
batmobile comes streaking out of the
fire and pummels the penguin's vehicle
sending him tumbling across the
interstate batman and jim gordon then
interrogate the penguin before
abandoning him for another lead while
the massive destruction on the
interstate is pulse-pounding it's
quickly forgotten by the film's
characters sure batman didn't cause the
destruction and yes this film is focused
on batman fighting out of hate not pope
as such it makes sense that the penguin
would be all he is concerned about
instead of helping the innocents among
the wreckage however the penguin
receives no consequences for those
actions and squeaky clean police
lieutenant jim gordon seems undeterred
by it as well the pileup was simply an
explosive action sequence without any
real effect it's also a bit of a head
scratcher
the batman is an engaging character
heavy story the film is anchored by a
talented cast who capably take on their
roles oz kabul pod the future penguin is
one character that is brilliantly
realized from head to toe makeup and
prosthetics ensure that we never
recognize colin farrell even if we know
he is somewhere underneath that rough
exterior feral perfects his performance
by depicting a wildly believable and
captivating mobster who cares very
little about anyone but himself batman
confronts the penguin on two separate
occasions the first time is more of an
amicable meeting as batman attempts to
find any information linking the mayor
to organize crime in the cesspool of
individuals that occupy the iceberg
lounge penguin sarcastically humorous to
dark knight later batman pursues the
penguin after learning that he may have
been the man who ratted on sal moroney's
illicit business operations however the
penguin isn't the man the caped crusader
is looking for in the interrogation the
penguin establishes himself as a bullish
yet witty individual who will do
anything to survive after all the
penguin is a survivor and even outlasted
carmine falcone and will soon secure
power for himself there's no doubt about
that while he doesn't get a ton of
screen time the penguin is absolutely
magnetic every time he appears on camera
everyone knows bruce wayne's tragic
backstory we also know that the death of
his parents leads alfred to become
bruce's surrogate family typically
positioned as a faithful servant to the
wayne family alfred stands by bruce
through thick and thin the batman even
establishes that he likely taught bruce
how to fight which means that alfred is
one tough cookie he even hints at the
idea that he may have been more of a
bodyguard to the wanes than just a
simple servant when he tells bruce that
he was supposed to protect thomas and
martha whatever the case may be there's
certainly a history between the two
that's begging to be explored however
the film doesn't really touch on the
relationship between the two in any
meaningful way sure alfred helps bruce
crack riddler ciphers he even takes the
full force of a bomb for bruce and is
hospitalized as a result but when bruce
finally tells alfred that he fears
losing someone he cares about it doesn't
exactly feel earned given the lack of
interaction between the two
despite batman's penchant for working
alone he needs allies beyond alfred
selena kyle fills that role in the
batman and zoe kravitz completely slays
in her performance as the famous cat
burglar maybe we're not so different
who are you under there as a character
she's far more multi-dimensional than
the always angry batman is at the start
of the film selena is compassionate
fiercely loyal to her friends and
extremely deadly in the right situations
when batman first catches her off guard
while breaking into a save she trades
blows with the dark knights and the two
have magnetic chemistry right away
when the big revelation drops at carmine
falconia selena's father and that she's
gunning for him a new side to the
character is unveiled selena doesn't
play around and regardless of any blood
relation messing with her friends might
earn you a bullet catwoman has always
been a conflicted figure who often
balances her thievery with her respect
for batman province's portrayal is
possibly the most accurate live-action
depiction of the character yet
batman is known for his famous bat cave
where all the toys and equipment reside
the batman does away with the idea of
the cave being below wayne manor instead
bruce wayne lives in a skyscraper and
his bath cave appears to be an abandoned
subway station creative choices abound
in the film and most of them are hits
however the lack of a substantial bat
cave while a nitpick might weigh heavily
on the hearts of bat fans the space
batman uses is in keeping with a
minimalist vibe one might get from the
early days of batman's career however it
also feels largely unimpressive and
uninspired the bat cave is an iconic
piece of batman's history that
ultimately deserves a certain reverence
in its depiction hopefully bruce wayne
will expand operations in the follow-up
film and take his work to a more
suitable home base
the batman is teeming with the crooks
thieves and killers that populate the
seedier side of gotham city the film
drops hints and clues about a larger
world of batman lore and characters that
the sequels can flesh out throughout the
riddler's campaign for justice he seeks
to assassinate the character of the
city's leadership by exposing their most
heinous truths to the public during some
of his ramblings that hit the airwaves
he discusses important figureheads in
gotham city like the arkham family one
of his newspaper clippings even
references edward elliot another popular
gothamite who helped modernize the city
his descendant tommy elliott even
becomes the villainous hush in the
comics later batman uses a venom-like
substance to receive a boost of
unbridled energy which indicates that
bane might be in batman's future
mentions of black gate prison arkham
state hospital and even bloodhaven are
woven in the film's dialogue these are
all locales iconic to batman lore
audiences even get a glimpse of arkham
with the riddler in his cell the film
even teases a popular batman villain who
cackles at the riddler's comeback plans
there's plenty happening within the
world of the batman making it one of the
film's best qualities for bat fans in
the film's opening moments batman saves
a man from a ruthless beating at the
hands of a gang clearly his goal wasn't
to save the man but to punish the wicked
after he frightens the goons away the
innocent man is afraid of batman and
begs a vigilante not to hurt him he
doesn't but neither does he offer any
message of comfort later in the film
batman ignores a mass pileup and
explosion on the freeway which likely
led to some casualties in order to catch
oz when celine asks for his help finding
a friend who is clearly in danger batman
cares more about retrieving intel than
the innocent whose life is on the line
he's even icy cold toward alfred and
calls him a liar after alfred wakes up
at the hospital the ending of the film
marks a welcome change in the character
as he focuses on providing hope to the
good citizens of gotham however it's
still hard to witness our hero so
enthralled in his quest for vengeance
that he forgets what it's like to be
human and ignores the plight of others
in distress check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the batman are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]